now here locally so many are still
coming together to show their support
for ukraine olympic figure skater aksana
bayul farina is one of those fighting
for her home country here in the valley
sasha loftus sat down with her tonight
and shares more in her message for those
who are suffering across the world
denise and brian oksana bayel lives in
las vegas now but she says part of her
heart still belongs to ukraine she wants
to raise awareness for all those
suffering there
it's just so sad oksana bayeul farina
shares the sadness she feels for her
home country every day is getting worse
and worse and worse and worse what's
happening in 1994 she was the first and
only ukrainian figure skater to win an
olympic gold at 16 i
stand up on the toughest podium
and
that national anthem played at the
olympic games for the first time now she
lives in las vegas and says her heart
breaks for her family and friends
singing that same anthem a world away
and trying their best to survive they're
sitting in the bomb shelters with their
pets without food without diapers
without medicine
russian president vladimir putin's
invasion of ukraine continues to
escalate as ukrainian officials say over
2 000 civilians have reportedly died and
a million have escaped in search of
safety
that's why oksana is standing up and
speaking out to raise awareness she
wants those facing unimaginable fear
6200 miles away
to know they are not alone there is
nothing more
we can do other than being
out there supporting them
naksana is holding a peace rally this
weekend to support her home country of
ukraine it's happening saturday
afternoon at las vegas city hall we have
more information on our website
8newsnow.com back to you